well Dania he's uh he's uh he's a bit of
a wall a wild cat uh he uh yeah I mean
that's not to say he can't play
positionally because of course every
Grand Master who reaches this level can
play but I think he certainly prefers
positions which are a bit more muddy a
bit more unclear uh where he can fight
for uh for the initiative
um and Anish well Anish said it in his
interview yesterday he's he's probably
the player that takes the least risks of
everybody in this field he is really
risk-averse
uh plays very solid simple chests as he
called it but he's very very hard to
beat almost impossible to beat actually
uh if he really doesn't want to lose
um
but we have something already a little
bit more exciting than I had envisaged
Anish with the move C4 here I don't know
well this is definitely in his notes we
have a an interesting version of a
caracom very new age
idea of 3d3 you didn't see this move
10 years ago it just didn't exist as an
opening 28 two years ago yeah even two
years ago
um
so some new opening theory in this line
and
we'll see what Daniel comes up with yeah
Ivanka you're the resident Curry yeah uh
what do you think of this variation yeah
I think black is actually doing okay
here I mean the main thing I would say
is
after White's third move do not be
tempted to go into an end game
the only thing anything else goes just
uh
let's just show this so any karakan
aficionados at home do not play porn sex
porn in this opening uh Ivanka why not
it looks like you can trade off the
Queens white loses the right to Castle
yeah I know it's just uh very pleasant
for white and uh yeah okay black
probably is okay but it's not worth it
just don't do it much simpler to keep
the Queens on the board and uh just play
in the style of uh narodeski yep
um the two moves to keep the Queens on
the board or three moves uh one you can
bring your Bishop out very tense middle
game there you can push this Pawn very
sensible but narratively move to Twin
the idea was to push forward with his uh
Pawn in the center and uh yeah as we saw
in the game a Trader Pawns
like pushing forward trying to make use
of a small development Advantage by
opening the center and
this position I'm surprised that
anisha's thinking here this is still
very well very logical stuff at least
as far as I remember the white Bishop
normally wants to go to this Square I'm
not sure whether you kind of push a pawn
to put it there yet I guess you could
also make an an argument for just moving
the bishop out getting the white king
castle and then deciding
it's uh yeah interesting opening not the
most just Orthodox have there been many
games here before not so many but I mean
they've been very high level I mean we
have a game between Alan pitcher against
Magnus Carlson uh Alan pitcher again
against David Anton Rasmus varnas paired
this with black so we're talking about
very very serious Grand Masters here and
I would say that the scores are
in Black's favor Black's favor wow
interesting and uh it's rare for any
opening to be in blacksaver in general
but uh I guess here Black's moves are
very natural black just wants to bring
his Bishop out Castle the king for white
it's less natural maybe you have to be a
bit creative what do we think about this
punt
Bishop to the G5 Square attacking this
Knight
looks like the most natural move on the
board to me actually because you want to
play a very quick Rook C1 in a lot of
lines and try to embarrass this queen on
C7
um and you know if black ever plays a
move like d takes C4 I think you're very
tempted just to just to ignore it
basically uh we're in the reality yeah
just play Rook C1 immediately
it's natural Lawrence but it's new
yeah I mean David highlighted earlier
exactly what they were doing that
everyone was kind of putting the bishop
on a long diagonal and then attacking
the queen this one never been seen
before so okay so Bishop G5 is a
completely new novel new movie new okay
I couldn't believe that I guess Black's
most logical replies would be to defend
this Knight either with his bishop or
maybe with the other Knight
I think can I can I throw an absolutely
insane suggestion out there yes it's too
insane boys it's too insane I wanted to
play the ridiculous move d4 I don't
think it quite works
um attacking this night hoping for
Knight takes porn yeah well I wanted to
make Queen E5 check work but I I can't
quite check hitting the Knight but just
guess I could just Retreat yeah Bishop
B3 and now some Bishop C5 but you have
Knight F3 it's total nonsense
um but it's interesting because okay not
exactly here but in some situations that
type of tactic yes it's always nice to
look for the threats right just in case
the opponents planted something
so yeah it feels like to me at least I
would want to make this move work Bishop
to this Square just so I can Castle as
quickly as possible I think that's the
most natural move and I think it does
work right
I think so I think it's after porn takes
porn you can actually oh
okay
you could take the night in the center
exactly and you would be okay but
naroditski he's happy to mix things up
he doesn't play the passive move that I
was advocating he brings his Bishop out
to create a pin and I say mix things up
because he's allowing his Pawn structure
to be compromised to be split
double pawns the black King's gonna
think twice now maybe before castling on
the side
but on the bright side there's some
tactics here now with the pin maybe you
use this file for a rook later this open
newly openg file
interesting stuff
yeah I don't know I don't I don't like
it David because it's not in a caracon's
player's nature to allow it's like
preserve the pawn structure then uh I'm
getting oh my God my instinct is you
know first of all Queen Jack
yeah and then and then initiate you the
trades so take take and now you can for
example take on this Square yeah that's
it has to recapture suddenly
there's I know I know I know black cats
like some active pieces in compensation
but I I don't know but I guess
nariditsky
um if we think about his tournament
situation he's on 13 anisha's on 17.
there's no one in between
he needs to win this game right yeah if
naroditski draws he'll be four points
behind Anish with three games remaining
that's not a realistic comeback right no
um narrative if he doesn't win this one
he'll have to win pretty much all of his
games tomorrow in order to qualify so a
position like this with a kind of whoops
weird Pawn structure
at least it will confuse Anish Anish
doesn't like kind of facing Dynamic play
Black's Bishop is now very quick to come
out Black's Rook gets an open file if
white wants to Castle on this side
it gets really complicated yeah and
Lawrence you said that his style was
just wild so
oh I think Daniel's going to be very
very happy with this position as black
to be honest uh it's it's it's messy
it's new it's exactly the sort of thing
Anish doesn't really uh
excellent uh of course he's a fantastic
tactician and he's he's a great player
but you know it's
it's not exactly what he wants I think
which is
curious because he didn't have to play
this way with white of course played one
E4 which is already a minor surprise I
would say from Anish but he's got a
chessable course out on money for he
does he does have adjustable course or
one E4 but yeah I mean naroditski his
repertoire's a bit kind of okay he's
placed Some solid stuff occasionally but
it's a bit random so maybe Anish was
trying to Target the karakan a lot of
players do that nowadays they can if
they know that what their opponent is
going to play whatever opening it is
they can Target their opponents
of weak spots or perceived weak spots
narrative ski I think he's done quite
well about out of the opening though
even if he is slightly freestyling yeah
and whilst Danish is pausing for thought
we have a question from Zhao campella
riviero who asks us
um apparently um
Do You Believe Magnus is under extra
pressure especially against younger
players since neem since the Neiman
incident since uh Hans is also a teen
[Music]
um
I don't I don't think those incidents
are sorry those things are actually that
related I think the younger generation
is always the threat to the older
generation I'm including Magnus in that
older generation he is over 10 years old
he's 10 years older or more than gukesh
Abdul saturov and so on if the third uh
all the stuff there in the tournament
actually Magnus culture he's the third
oldest in the tournament so but I don't
think the Neiman incident actually has
got anything really to do with age per
se
um I think that I think those things are
isolated but for sure he feels the
pressure from the younger generation but
he also uses it as his source of
motivation after all he's been playing
the same guys year in year out for 10
years and he wants some fresh blood and
he he gets it so you know I speak to him
I hang out with him and he tells me that
he looks forward to seeing the
progression of these Young Guns do you
think when it is
when they qualify for the World
Championship Match do you think miners
will make a comeback and play in the
candidates
really tough to say because the Cycles
are quite long as well right so even
let's say Abdus Satora was to win a
candidates in two years from now and
then he challenged that's another four
years and then Magnus would have to
re-challenge an already Magnus is
getting close to 40 by that stage
yeah there we go that's the uh that's
the reality of it uh does he want to get
back in the mix
who knows what do you think I mean I
have a feeling that he's he's he's he's
kind of
done now
um if Hans Neiman becomes world champion
that'll add an interest that'll add a
little little bit of spice to the
situation I'd like the quote that he
came up with yesterday which one quite
nice
said I'm I'm just an improving player
on the road to the World Champ on on the
road to becoming world champion or
something yeah yeah
[Music]
but you know this is the thing most
chess players are confident but he's
like Hans is probably like the first one
to come out
and go yeah
I'm just playing great yeah wonderful
chess it speaks for itself it is next
level confidence yeah yeah
either way it's just the circle of life
right it's I mean if we look back in
chess history I mean Boris basket was
the world champion Fisher a younger
rival came up and took his crown and
then later on karpov was world champion
a younger rival Kasparov took his crown
it's always 10 15 years difference
between the players and
um and Magnus took the crown for vision
and who was what about 20 years older
than him and it's always just a crown
that took it from Kasparov who was like
10 15 years older than him it's always
the Next Generation it's very rare for
someone of the same generation to take
the crown from arrival it's always
it's always people who see chess
differently who kind of have a new
different brand of Chess who come and
take over eventually and meanwhile this
game is uh is changing slightly the
queen side of the board what do we think
about that
I think it favors uh White actually I
mean
these weak pawns that like have I mean
that that's going to be a liability in
the end game the thing is if you're
playing with the white pieces then you
have to neutralize the bishop pair
yep and black does have that to at least
try and enjoy the bishop pair
black dark Square Bishop has decent
potential I feel
um the black light squared Bishop might
just have to do a defensive job
are we surprised that naroditski took
the Queen's off just just considering we
think he's in a muscle in situation is
that something that's on his mind or is
he just trying to play the position
maybe rather than worry about results
yeah I was surprised by some of his
choices I thought he could have kept the
Queens on and just tried to pressure the
white king a little bit but I think
maybe it was a bit too risky too
double-edged and he didn't feel it was
worth a risk you go to risk sometimes
especially if naroditski doesn't win
this game now and uh he doesn't really
have much chance going into tomorrow to
qualify for the Knockouts then he might
look back at the queen Exchange
as uh maybe not the most
ambitious decision that being said I
still quite like Black's chances uh
narajitski talking to himself there
motivating himself I wonder if when he
talks to himself he puts on the accents
the uh Impressions The Impressions right
yeah
what would Gary say you know you know
anyone there is he would do his accents
too this is a surprising trade you mean
you were talking to David about how
great the dark Square Bishop was well at
least it had no rival right yeah Bishop
pair is always much stronger stronger
than a lone Bishop
I quite like White's Pawn structure now
as well white isolated Pawn in the
center is no longer I mean white has a
couple of Pawns on the DNC files White's
a pawn it's fine for now
I don't understand anything Daniel has
done in this past five moves I mean this
is insanity to me positional suicide I
mean you could have played Bishop E6
instead of taking on C3 let's show this
yeah uh I mean this is the most logical
move in the whole position defend you
can take this one later if you really
need to yeah
very strange I mean here as well you can
even just park your king in the center
at some point and just sit and wait and
Rock Solid but now Bishop takes takes
and
okay I was Anish uh he's placing playing
the move I was gonna suggest as well if
white can just kind of put the king in
the center these pawns are safe forever
and eventually you can go about trying
to attack these guys maybe reroute the
White Knight
I would love to kind of move the white
knighting put it one square forward
takes a while to get there but and and
if you trade off the Bishops the king is
gonna be the big attacker yeah I mean
the King has a clear path in and if the
Rooks disappear for example into some
decent squares
black has one isolated born two isolated
pawns and a set of double pawns white
has only one weakness
so it's better to have fewer porn
islands and here white has one this is a
pawn Island uh these two in the center
were born Island they can defend each
other and this is another Pawn Island on
the king side black meanwhile has one
two uh three and four so that's a lot
and a lot of weaknesses to watch out for
later
quick maths maths quick I mean quit
counting I can count to four yes that's
what you need to be a Grandmaster I was
quoting that song I love that Amber who
does it quick maths one is one is one
plus one is two oh I don't know that
song
parody of these rappers in in hoodies oh
right okay but he's like won't take he
won't take his jacket off it's very good
all right I'll have to check it out I
don't know it Twitter follow his Twitter
viewers must yeah man's not hot that's
what it's called man it's about it's
about a rapper that does not take off
his his puffer jacket okay okay because
I know man's not hot
well Magnus Carlson's been playing with
a hoodie it's off today and he is right
now playing against Nils crandallius
it's had a tough day Magnus Carlsen and
the bar is over to Nelson side in that
game maybe struggling a little bit in
that one Magnus I don't know
and I'm also noticing Aditya metal the
youngest player an international Master
the bar is definitely over to his side
in his game against Arjun Eric icy maybe
we will have some interesting results in
this round 12.
yeah I took a look at those games that
you just mentioned Kion both of them
crazy wow especially at due to a detail
metal he's doing very well nice okay
so still some shake up on the standings
potentially yeah I mean while black has
doubled up Brooks on the C file makes
some sense and a niche guarding
everything
let's talk about Anish do we think he's
going to finish this one off it is his
type of position
in general as we said yesterday
yes I mean even though I've not liked
the Way Dania has played his position is
still
acceptable
but
I wouldn't say fun though not fun yeah
but what what what is the plan here for
why that's that's a really good question
um so we think black is just gonna sit
tight and
kind of wait
yeah I think I think you have to sit
tight uh well what else can you do here
that's a good question I'm slightly
surprised by this move from Anish that
was my first Bishop that was my first
move what's the Deep idea behind I don't
think there is but there are some
interesting ideas for example if black
plays Bishop G4 here Knight D4 might be
a cute little idea the point being if
Bishop takes D1 Knight B5 check exists
so we're even in an end game we're
playing for tricks yeah and
looks like it's gonna swap off pieces
but Knight to D4
and like you said attacking the bishop
Bishop takes with the flicking check
with this Knight yeah we just win
material right yeah this is just winning
we take the black rook and only then do
we take the black Bishop later
um and if you take the Knight first then
we take the bishop first hitting the
rook and hitting the Knight and after
Knight E6 yeah this has got to have been
about now A5 for example is the movie
before this is why it's dream to trade
off the isolated Pawn for these two
strong ones right
correct okay so he's gone on an
adventure with his Knight to the edge of
the board
hitting the bishop Bishop is just
probably going to step back to the
square it came from yeah and there we go
you're right and this helps white right
I always thought the idea was to get the
white tonight to this square and he's
going back no Anish don't repeat no it's
happening what what
is better such a weird white has an
advantage and he's just bails out with a
draw what is that about is that over is
that confirmed he's got back his Knight
black moved his Bishop he moved his
Knight the bishop went back and they
repeated This Dance
objectively he knows he was better I
think he's just playing on the
tournament standings and he's